hello
how's it going everyone
yeah I I think I I should be audible now
can you hear me
yeah I can hear you yeah that's great
let's do a quick uh video test
yep
I can also see you
maybe I'll just yeah yeah
it should be fine I guess
uh
it should be it should be easy to share
the screen yeah hold on
um yeah there should be a
button at the bottom saying share screen
yeah I see the button but I may try to
disable the video while I'm sharing
because uh yeah I'll just say let's do
like just a screenshotting test
foreign
[Music]
yeah I'm just uh I'll just stopped like
sharing the spin for a moment
nice Christmas sweater Chris
Handmade by my uh by my friend's mother
in Norway
[Music]
honestly why are you laughing you're
kind of proof it was like perfect timing
she does she she also just approves of
moving too much apparently
those two also act like a Christmas
sweater the tiny one
no she she would kill me if I put her in
any type of clothes
like we tried doing
we tried doing the harness a while ago
like a couple of years ago she hated it
I think it would be very like the
Christmas card
sorry
I think it will be very good photo on on
the Christmas card like you and her
matching sweaters I actually might try
that for this year's postcards
slash Christmas cards
I'll be expecting one
you got it is there a return address on
the package
I think so okay good
yeah
did you
I your background is different like the
rocket that's very close to you used to
be on the other wall
yeah this uh it's a piece of furniture
and finally arrived like we already did
like a long time ago and it's like
finally here is that a tilco
no it's a
what's the name of the comics like a
Berlin company
um
oh
it's essentially like Lego so you buy
blocks and here you can stack them the
way you want we got one of these for the
office but it was like a different
company I just suppose that there's many
of them
I guess it's like it's not like a
revolutionary idea to have like building
blocks for furniture
okay
cool so people are a little bit coming
in how are you going everyone
nice
great going pretty good how about you
I'm fine thanks
you you open a PR on evaluated right
last week yeah let's be
it's nice to put a face in a PR
thanks for all the help I'm sorry for
the bumbling almost
yeah I think like there were some test
defending but it wasn't your fault it's
like the CI at the moment is like very
annoying kind of change it
cool that's maybe where it's uh another
minute or so
yeah honestly honestly to be fair I'm uh
yeah I would just say it turn my weapon
for a month I'm just I'm just happy that
we did that test and the reason why is
because when I decided to run the zoom
zoom decided to self update so I was
waiting at the beginning
classic soon
well I mean it's like the thing that
always happens to me on the map is like
if you use a platform the first time you
have to say like this application is
allowed to use your camera and you can
only do that when you're like restart
the application
yeah it's so important in my career I
was just like running hourly news and it
was nice to like decide when you can
update then I decided to like switch to
Microsoft stuff and I decided to be
greeted by uh by a Windows update and
and I was thinking that I'm done like
Windows updated got better but honestly
recently I was in the middle of doing
something and doing those updates I
decided to review the size simultaneous
everything so
yeah I I always really hate it when
Windows does that to you like forcing
you to updates like I I'm grown up I can
decide myself when I want to update I
don't want to be told like you have to
update in an hour
yeah I think I I think in the Enterprise
Edition there's like there's an option
to like uh turn it off for for a while
like I think like two weeks maybe I'm
I'm not sure like at least it was like
for Windows 10 Enterprise but but yeah I
was I was basically thinking to some
extent how much is like the end result
of like uh having like the same product
pretty much both for Enterprise and for
customers because I mean there's like
this separate like licensing tier like
Windows 10 Enterprise or not with
Windows 11 I'm not going into that but
basically it's like the same windows at
the end of the day
but yeah maybe not let's not dive into
the great days of like Windows
millennium
yeah today's reading reading topic is
like Windows XP the best Windows
90. well I think no no wait no I'm not
gonna let that pass
95 is the best Windows what are you
talking about
how old are you Chris
almost as old as you what are you
aren't you like 23 or something
nope
I'm 30.
31.
anyway
let's go let's go back to the topic I
think we made it uh long enough uh
welcome everyone to I think it's a
fourth edition of the the recently
Finance like going really fast
um today I'm asked how much is that's
the right way to pronounce your name
uh
how much I kindly agreed to give like a
brief overview of the named energy
recognition chapter
um so I think like without much more
introduction I hand over to you I think
you mentioned that we can do it kind of
like interactively and please like your
presentation kind of as a starting point
to for discussions and questions
yeah it doesn't take yeah because of the
presentation is more like to facilitate
like the toxins like discussion and not
to like go like linearly like from the
beginning
so I would try to launch the
presentation but I would like disabled
that video to like just make sure I'm
not like over utilizing the pump with ah
hold on
you can also if you have like questions
during the talk you can post them in the
chat and I can try to kind of like sort
and facilitate them
yeah great and all right the
presentation should be visible right uh
can you see it now
yes and that's great I've just I just
want to try to launch maybe so uh
with yeah that's great yeah so I I
decided to analyze pretty much like the
chapter 4 which is like multilingual
name entity recognition and without my
bunker details I I wanted to like focus
on like a big picture and this is why I
like I separated Linguistics the models
and the details and the reason why is
because as I was reading the book I was
I was finding myself like focusing on
like some of the like implementation
details and I was losing like the big
feature so that's why I pretty much
decided to like uh abstract Linguistics
the models and then like maybe like
talked about details if anyone wants to
so I so I decided like a bit like in
front of me so I I pretty much like
start over pretty much AWS and software
engineering then I I decided into Azure
and data engineering and even though at
this point like people are asking me why
why I would decide to do so because like
I would say in 2017 it wasn't like it
wasn't quite like extreme to do like
data engineering with Azure or like
generally like data stuff in Azure but
at this point I was like kind of like
predicting what would happen and how now
pretty much like Microsoft has like
doing like the data stock and at this
point it was interesting to see
Microsoft experimenting with open source
like data stuff basically like pretty
much they were trying to like Implement
Hadoop on their on their products and
they were pretty much like playing with
that and and I kind of expand into like
mixing that also to some extent with law
and ethics and and this includes like
licensing stuff or basically basically
the staff at the pretty much at the edge
of like
uh I would say ethics law and partial
learning so for example I was I was
recently researching how easily it got
to like swap faces in in machine
learning models and as a result how easy
it is to swap faces when people don't
want to be like their faces to be
swapped like some like gray areas around
that but yeah I would not go into
details I'm also like hosting machine
learning news Twitter spaces and and I
we pretty much like covered last time
with the final Discord and what was
happening there what has been happening
in France especially with data
protection and if anybody wants like
further or join the next Twitter space
that we are hosting I also like included
the QR code and I can guarantee that the
QR code is safe because I was entering
myself so at least at least it should be
so and and there are like other ways
like contact me on on Twitter on on
Mastodon oh I did the typo like never
mind I should include another another
person so yeah but never mind and I also
like blog on the website
so yeah after the future let's go into
yeah so I decided to start with
Linguistics and the reason why is
because
the chapter focuses on the on the
language situation in Switzerland and I
got the impression at the beginning that
I didn't kind of uh I didn't kind of
kind I would say cross the languages so
I decided to like extract like a free 10
likes and or I would say three key life
sentences and the idea is to extract
like key sentences from the languages
and have them like at the same time like
in different languages and the goal is
to like have like a grasp of how
languages is processing and the context
of the chapter four is that basically in
the chapter four pretty much uh what was
happening was fine tuning it on German
and then and then pretty much wondering
why it translates or why it why the
model performs better when when it's
when it's uh
when the model is done in German and
it's trying to run one shot French and I
would say as I was thinking about that
why it was happening I was just like
analyzing languages I decided to pretty
much summarize it by this and the reason
why is because I came into a conclusion
that the reason why
the reason why the model pretty much is
performing battle between German and
French and Italian and it's not
performing great on English is because
pretty much English English doesn't
doesn't have like gender articles this
much I'd say like there are some some I
would say specific scenarios Spanish
General and I was I was basically
thinking about going through this
chapter like that something something
that I was learning about is basically
that even though like NLP abstracts it
away to some extent like it's like is
the job of the model to extract those
patterns it's like requires some some
language knowledge
memes yeah but basically I was
I was basically thinking that even
though like even even though like it was
kind of I would say explaining the book
I was kind of like missing like the
Linguistics parts and I was I was
basically wondering that even though
like uh even though the as I was saying
the job of NLP is to like figure out the
patterns there's still like some like
gray area between like the model
figuring out the patterns and you like
fine-tuning the model and and then I was
I was basically uh hold on because I
think the presentation got
uh Vlog for a moment
yeah great so as I was basically going I
was thinking that this is like this is
like the point about like articles that
basically this was the reason why the
model was performing first and to
and as I was going I was also thinking
that one of the issues as I was going
the book was basically realizing that I
kind of forgot what was the goal of the
model and what is happening through the
model so that's why I decided to
separate like that that pretty much the
base model was was was pretty much
created from the common crowd data and
the Italian pretty much the interesting
part about common crowd data is that it
was Data gathered like crowing websites
and the interesting thing about that is
that there are there are some like legal
legal issues around that and the reason
why is because because pretty much the
legal basis for correcting common crowd
data is is fair use and some people are
not happy and the reason why because
fair use is pretty much the way to
extract copyrighted data and use it like
for purposes while not like while pretty
much not like I would say respecting
copyright or not basically some people
are not happy that like uh copyrighted
data is used at the basis of fire users
so this is like somebody that I've
served and and that to some extent was
come from Battleship but uh yeah pretty
much it was pretty much that was the
story behind behind excellent Roberta
that the data like from crowing the
internet was other
and I decided to like also like separate
photos by tuning so pretty much the idea
was that we have like the base model the
pretty much the base model that was
gathered from the common crowd data and
then we fine-tuted on the specific class
and this in this case the task is uh is
is pretty much the multilingual name
entity recognition and we train for like
Chrome stream code data and what I found
in probably like the most interesting
about that is that basically we can
Trend only on one language basically we
can fine-tooth it online one language
but at the same time we can also find
tweet it in multiple languages so
so at the end of the day I I would say
the kind of like the interesting part
was that even though the starting point
was like multilingual model we can just
fine-tooth it on a single language and
we can still like receive quite decent
results except as I was going to be far
above the spicy man basically that if we
find it on German then English
performance first but French is still
good so
yeah I was I was trying basically to
like summarize the and as I was going I
realized that something that I was
missing like through like I would say
the entire reading of the book is that
pretty much uh that there is like there
is uh there is the Roberta model in the
hugging phase there is also like there
are also like more like specific models
and there's also another expansion that
SLI pretty much of like trying the model
like deeper and this is something that I
wanted to mention specially if someone
went through like the book and realized
that where are the models so I wanted to
mention that aside from that Roberta
that's like in the hugging phase there
are also like the models that were
trained and this is something that I
wish it was like I like pointed out in
that bookmark because I realized that
there are models and they took me like a
while to like got to their models that
were trained in the chapter so it's
pretty much the number 12 if somebody
didn't realize that it's there
and and this is like something that I
realized as another part as I was trying
to like different this is this is like a
shout out to party for platinum from
Target face because uh was pretty much
kind of the reason why I discovered that
and the reason why is because I spotted
on Twitter and the interesting part
about like doing that was the lingual
stable diffusion is that is the stable
diffusion but the basic part is also
based on Roberta and and there are some
languages supported but the interesting
part is that I I mentioned a language is
supported and this is because the base
model Roberta supports around 100
languages and the stable diffusion model
from hagging face or outside the stable
diffusion model that's there supports
like less languages like for example for
example I I I I was trying to I was
trying to generate images and enjoyment
and it took me a while to realize that
German is not supported so this is the
reason why I I obviously like motionless
and it was interesting to see that like
how how how another model can be based
for another model
and that was like pretty much it for
what I I Was preparing that as I enjoy
if anybody like has more questions or
wants to dive into other directions oh
and and I wanted to like mention that
kind of the reason to do like PowerPoint
was because PowerPoint is also like nice
automated compatibility to like to like
generate slides so this was pretty much
also yeah I can pretty much like
automate the process so it was like kind
of the reason also I I decided to go
with my apartment
foreign
advertisement for Microsoft and office
but it's cool
um are there any questions or things
that you would like to discuss
ion
yeah could you and somebody else give
some uh
um a few lines of a summer edition
about you know the training of the
modelingo
uh you know each English or you know all
you know you know I I'm sorry I didn't
finish I did not read the chapter before
you know I was running out of time if
you can give a few lines of some
realization about the multilingual
training
you know
that would be great sure yeah I mean so
in three sentences roughly uh what the
chapter is about is like you can use
them a model like xlnr or xlm Roberta
um that's been pre-trained on many
languages so it has been pre-trained on
roughly 100 languages
um make the same goal as bird
essentially so you just predict like uh
last words
um but if you do that on many languages
you kind of like profit from this
cross-lingual transfer everything kind
of discussing in a chapter and what we
show is if you take a model that has
been pre-trained on many languages and
you fine-tune it on even just one
language for example doing an entry
recognition or sentence classification
it can generalize to the other languages
that it was pre-trained on it's like if
you speak to languages and I explain to
you what sentimental classification is
in one language you might be able to
transfer it to another language and
these multilingual language models
they're kind of similar
and uh yeah what's kind of interesting
is you can even sometimes beat a
monolingual model if you have like this
Crossing will transfer and you have a
lot of resources in some languages that
kind of run surrounding
I don't know that summarizes it
a little bit
okay so when training with multiple
languages I guess you just randomly pick
up some articles from each language
versus you know you pair them up with a
translation for example you might have
two articles one English one in German
you know or it's exactly the same
article translation but I guess that's
another way to go right you just pick up
random article for the training right
yeah so I think there have been several
approaches there have been models that
kind of used alignment so where you have
some data that is in multiple languages
and then you align the the data the
sentences for example in emission French
and you do some master language modeling
um using both sentences so the the model
has kind of a translated between those
five parallel purposes
um and there have also been approaches
where you don't do that and you should
scale to have like more data essentially
I guess the letter way will be more
prevailing because it's less effort
yeah exactly you don't have to do less
um to do that but for example I think uh
Facebook they have trained like these
translation models for example one is
called
um M2M I think 100 and it's a
translation model that can translate
between 100 languages and there they had
to align
um
the data sets so they had to find like
sentences in multiple languages that are
uh contact people like parallel
um but they they kind of like a cool
approach they use like um their version
embeddings It's like a tool they call a
laser I think
um and it's like word embeddings or
sentence embeddings like multiple
languages and they use that to kind of
like take a big data set of multilingual
data and finding sentences that are
actually the same across multiple
languages and they synthetically created
a huge data set with like bird pairs
products to train these language models
these translations thanks
sure
um there's a question
uh there's a question about asking a
question can we only ask questions
related to the Transformers book
um no I think you can also ask other
questions ideally they're kind of
related to the topics that we're talking
about but it doesn't need to be
necessarily about like a certain Topic
in the book
um so there's another question uh is
token classifier output I recommend for
the output of our custom nermo and it
had just return a dictionary with keys
lots of the features
um so I think you might
be able to do that it depends a little
bit how much you want to use of the
transformative ecosystem so I think for
example if you use the trainer
um I think it expects like these class
output class
to get like certain attributes from your
model outputs I'm not 100 sure but I'm
pretty sure that's the case if you just
use your remodel
um like in your own code and you have
your own training Loop
um and if it's easier for you to deal
with dictionaries you can do that
um that being said that token classifier
output class behaves kind of like a
dictionary so it's like it has some
additional functionality but it's like
um original dictionary
uh Leandro I had a question
sure
um I think there's something like really
interesting or profound about doing this
task in the chapter like the fact that
we can just trade on lots of different
languages and just generalize to them is
not very intuitive to me so I was
wondering if there's if anyone has kind
of figured out what the models are
actually abstracting and learning when
they are performing well across
languages like is there a linguistic
rule or Theory that's being learned
inherently in the model that allows it
to generalize so well or do we even know
what's happening under the hood that's
kind of what I'm really curious about
because I don't think it's intuitive at
all that this should work beyond the
fact that there are similar languages in
the world and that they might use nouns
or whatever similarly
yeah that's a good point I don't think I
have like a very good answer to that
um maybe somebody else has I mean I can
give you like my two cents which is
roughly
um like these models they have like
limited capacity right and they have to
learn a lot of things across a lot of
languages or like 100 languages and you
have to learn the things so the one way
you can efficiently do that is you if
you compress as much information as
possible from these different languages
right if you see similar patterns and if
you look at kind of like
um for example people looked at computer
vision models where they if you look at
the different layers they start to
abstract more and more right as you go
deeper so you start with like very
superficial features like in in computer
videos like the edges and coronaries and
like textures and as you as you go
deeper you go to more abstract
um attributes like if there's a
combination of these kind of actions
that's a phase or is that like that's a
bicycle or a car
um and the way I think about it it's
like the transformer is similar where
you sort of like superficial features
which are words and then as you go
deeper through the network it probably
abstracts in some way these like super
professional features in more
let's say like semantic representations
of what things they are like for example
folder is an abstract meaning right
that can be in many in many different
words in within the same language so
maybe uh they can learn similar things
across languages
that's why how I think about it but it's
not like founded in any observation
that's more my mental model at the
moment
that's fair I just think it's the really
interesting thought that I think it's
important to press upon you know
I think that's related to interpretation
of a machine learning deep learning I
mean it's a
it's it has been in discussion for a
while
but looks like there's no
really great way to interpret it's hard
it's hard to interpret it just works
I think like the the folks at anthropic
they did like some great very frequently
on that topic the other day
like last time like marketing well it's
a bit more about like about Transformers
work they they look advice simplified
version of Transformers like if it only
has like one layer or two layers can you
like interpret what the attention is
doing actually uh and they are like
really cool blog posts but
um they're like weekends long I think
like like 50 pages or so it's more like
a tiny book but uh they're doing like
some awesome work on them if you're
interested in that
and that's pretty much why I was
wondering that this is like pretty much
like the shared responsibility model but
like responsibility model not like for
the cloud but for for NLP and the reason
why because NLP like figures out some
stuff while while on the other hand it's
still like your job to understand some
of the Linguistics to fine-tune the
models
yeah I think it has also been a trend in
that right first like I think 10 years
ago or so
um
the the way to do NLP was more coming
from the linguistic side and tried to
like extract features that the
correspond to like things that we know
they should correspond to like trees of
like the structure of sentences and what
happened a little bit was like
lstms or later Transformers is like if
you just throw a lot of data at it it
actually can learn these features
themselves so you don't need to
handcraft them which is also nice and
gives you uh gives them all more
flexibility right because it can extract
the features that are interesting or
useful
and can I say that's the reason why we
don't need to know a lot of linguistics
knowledge in order to do the energy work
I'm not sure that that's an accurate
statement though
um you definitely need a lot of NLP of
linguistics knowledge to assess what
models are doing whether they're failing
in ways that can be and should be
avoided
um but just to go back Leonardo to what
you were saying about how it used to be
and how it is now I there's a talk by
Ashish vasvani first authored on the on
the attention paper and and he says very
explicitly uh like that was like early
days before it exploded he says that
we did like this isn't proto-quoting and
we did not come up with a good inductive
bias for language we came up with a good
inductive bias for just like paralyzing
all the layers so like he very like
there's this awareness that this is all
data driven that this is not like better
than lstms on on a theoretical level
because like theoretically if you like
close your eyes and forget all the
successes
an lscm is still a much better way to to
to at least like theoretically model the
sequence it's just that we it does not
run well when you want to paralyze it on
like a thousand machines
yeah
I think that's also
very good no go for it I talk too much
uh no I had a question about other the
the objectives like the mass language
modeling and uh
predicting the next word and the
sentence grounded in linguistics or
these are just objectives that people
have thought of
that that leveraged like sentence
structure which is like a slings and
something
I I think that they are probably like
similar grounded to to what Chris just
said like it's just a very efficient and
useful way to do things and it turns out
that these models actually learned quite
a lot of things by with these objectives
right like if you want to predict an
expert or you want to predict a mask for
it you have to know a little bit uh
what's around it but it's also I don't
think like the end of the story I think
that I've been like some Mercury can be
looking at that against like should it
really just be one word should it be a
spanned should it be like multiple spans
things like that where you try to make
the task like and you're suited that the
model learns more
it looks like Chris wants to say
something
no I was just thinking about like how
how ad hoc it is to come up with these
objectives
because like moving from bird to Roberta
people said let's just drop next
sentence prediction and it worked better
whereas like the intuition at the time
was like next sentence prediction this
is giving you like some sort of global
coherence and masking is giving you some
sort of like local coherence but it
turns out that no
this is something to do with lots of
lots of data is making it work
for like the specific task but
also shows you that that it's like an
empirical field right it's not like you
can't it both also the next sentence
prediction sounds like something that's
reasonable right like oh if you want to
predict if something's an expert then
probably you need to understand
something about language so let's add it
then then you're on Summer Place like ah
actually actually no
yeah we're sort of like moving back to
like the the image of the experimental
scientists just like trying random
things and some things work most things
don't
but I mean for domestic language
modeling that's actually that wasn't
like an entirely novel thing with the
Transformer if you look at how virtual
record is done it's pretty much the same
thing right of X factors are also
learned by predicting like what's the
verbs in the middle or predicting the
surrounding word of the word so
like
predicting words out of context has been
like uh
an objective like for a while
um
well one comment I wanted to make about
your statement about
um
digital former mainly means its main
strength being like a patient and
paralyzable it's like have you read like
The Bitter lesson from Rich seven uh I
have no no
but it's like he's uh he's the guy who
like kind of like the father of modern
reinforcement learning um I think she's
a deep mind
and uh he wrote the reinforcement
learning book yeah yeah I was just
looking for it just like I recognized
the name
and uh he wrote like an article I think
like one or two years ago called
computer lesson and it was it was
interesting about the topic of like
feature engineering and and making
models work and he was saying like in in
the past like I don't know 20 years or
so what has been proven to win all the
time are the models that actually scale
not the models that are like smart
crafted so people try to come up with
like handcrafted filters for cnns and
putting them together but actually just
making a very efficient architecture
that's scalable and has like a good
objective
um when it's kind of like why the rest
methods uh so successful
and then also the Transformers like you
can just throw more compute at it and it
kind of scales quite efficiently and you
can see that it gets better
so it's like the winning factor is like
coming up with mixed methods that are
kind of simple and that scale good with
like compute
like a winning combination and he said
it's better because as as like a
researcher you think like I'm gonna
create that very smart feature it's like
I I was a data scientist people are very
average like with tables also and you
think like I'm gonna come up with like a
very smart way of describing like I
don't know a customer so and then it
turns out like if you have enough data
all these things that can be learned
like a few of these cheated by by a
stupid algorithm
yeah absolutely I mean
Andrew could you talk a little bit about
the body under the head I saw in the
chapter you know in a sense head is kind
of a allow you some flexibility to
extend the functionality uh you know to
different uh tasks
uh I guess that's fine tuning right
um
and the body might be just the
pre-training am I right to say that
what's the fine line between the uh uh
pre-training and the the the fine tuning
sure so I mean when you when you
pre-train a model right what you have is
like you have the body is essentially
all the layers of the model except like
the last one
and if you do free training the last
layer so at the what goes through the
layers essentially like the
representation of the tokens and the
sentences that go into the model and as
they travel like through through your
model
um these representations get refined in
a sense and in pre-training at the very
end there is a layer that takes these
representations and it has to predict
the word right either it's the last word
or if it's like a mod like CPT it's an
expert that you have to predict
um but now if you want to do
classification that that last layer just
the shape of it doesn't make any sense
anymore right because you maybe you
don't want to predict the token like a
token prediction essentially like a very
large classification
so you can replace that layer but you
reuse everything else and everything
else has learned useful things as we
said before right like just predicting
the mask word it helps the the model
learn like useful representations of
tokens and tokens in in their context
and we can reuse that if you want to do
classification so you just take uh uh a
new Final layer to it
um that has to be trained too because
that's usually just randomly initialized
um but it's like less than a percent or
so of all the weights that are in your
model so it's very efficiently
efficiently between that or very fast
let's say usually you still train all
the weights because maybe
a model can learn something new and it's
usually quite quick because most
learning is happening in that last
player that's here
but that's what uh in the book we called
had because it seems like fitting
we can call this ner ahead right name
and recognition uh name entity this is
the head right
yeah
and they're like for all novels usually
they're like many head study countries
there's a classification there there's
an entry recognition head
in other chapters we use like a question
answering that that's more about like
detecting spans instead of tokens
um and one one of the goals of the
chapter was because we actually show how
that head looks like in code is you can
write your own head if you have your own
task
um so if you I don't know maybe you have
like three classifications that you want
to do in parallel so you want to have
like a special classification ad it's
not that much of a code to uh come up
with it
another question I have uh this is also
related to here so when you initialize
with a pre-training model you initialize
with the weight but also the contextual
embedding right you are using the
contextual embedding trend from the
pre-training model am I right
yes so the contact contextual weights
are I don't think they're different from
the weights so the weights of the model
they make the contextual embeddings
later on
it's what goes into to the models or
just the tokens
um and then they're contextualized
embeddings are
built based on the weights of the models
and other layers so I wouldn't
differentiate I would just say like you
have grades
so you you you you you you you
think they are interchangeable
to wait and the contextual embedding
they're the same or what
so the contextual embedding is more the
result of what comes out of the model if
so what comes out of like each of these
layers is like an embedding for each
component that you have in your input
and these embeddings they're like
they're computed when you pass
um a sentence or so they're they're not
like stored internally that you have
like a contextualized embedding for each
feature those are like invert when you
do like many used models
so they're more results that the weights
are like storing the logic and the the
uh the contextualized embeddings are
like the result of applying that logic
to the input you have
okay
I hope that doesn't confuse more than
terrifies
it's still a little bit confusing I
guess I need to Google a little bit more
sure yeah also feel free to ask more uh
questions on on this course episode
happy to try to answer
and uh yeah contextualized embedding
system it just means that's the
representation of the verb based on the
surroundings that the model produces and
the way it produces it is with the
weights that's kind of the semantics I
would say
um let me see are there any questions in
in the chat
yeah I would say sorry that I found
interesting is how much like there's the
there's like there are some like
security issues that and what I mean is
that I think to some extent it's like
similar like
executables that basically when you have
like when you have like big models like
Roberta or anything for that matter and
you train those models there are some
there are some like liars to attack
especially to put some vectors in the
base model and this is also something
that I've seen the contest of parking
place because basically it says hugging
face is becoming like repository for
models I was wondering like whether like
I really like going are you planning or
are you like have you been moderate
about like scanning the models or
basically like also like the
vulnerability part of it
um so that's a like a very tough problem
there are several layers to that so
um one thing you're mentioning is like
kind of like robustness though is the
model like susceptible to kind of attack
so you can make it do things that maybe
you don't plan to have people do with it
um I guess one one example is like you
train a model and you want to to be like
create safe content but depending on
like how you prompt it or kind of like
converts your input
um you might still find ways to exploit
it I think every company these days that
creates a demo of like a large language
model is it that is humor like instantly
thousands of people try to make the
model of course like the worst things
that you can think of
um that's like a really tough problem
and the research problem
the other thing is can you detect if
somebody intentionally made a bad model
right maybe somebody trained a model
just to create racist slurs
um that's quite similar it's really hard
to see from the weights of the model if
that's happening
um at the moment the way it's done is
mostly through reporting so if people
are recording bad things we try to
moderate them in some sense
and the last thing is which is probably
like the the most the more obvious like
uh security issue is the way for example
python models are stored they're usually
like often tickled or something like
that and you can have executable code in
those models right so when you load a
model actually some code can can get
executed
um and that would be like pretty bad
because then you could say like oh let's
look at my new Arsenal model everybody
should use that and then you install
like construction horses all over the
community
um for that last case there are like a
few things that we're doing
um one is there's a security scanner on
the app
so if you upload things on the unfaced
tab the scanner goes uh through the
files and see if there's any malware
embedded and it's also are uploaded
and we're working on a new library
called safe tensors that's like an
alternative to saving models Pi torch
models that doesn't allow for executable
code to be in there
um a fun fact is like I work hard quite
often with models for code and I created
some data sets for code and they
constantly constantly get hit by the
security scanner because there's a lot
of malware on GitHub and if you upload
them to the hub it's lights up like a
Christmas tree and you can see all the
files that have like security issues
yeah and just to put like a bit more in
context the reason why I was wondering
because is because hugging face like has
the capability of like trending models
or like models of the week so I was
wondering whether someone can create
something like trendy that will become
like trending and and by the time people
realize that it's like malware it will
be already downloaded by many people so
I was basically wondering how much like
also like the trending capability of
hugging faces also at the same time like
pretty much an attack vector
I think the the
security scanner is pretty quick so I
think before something can become
trending it's very likely that the
scanner has been done through and you
should see like a red flag
if if there's like malware content in
the other cases if it's just a model
that produces like harmful content
then as far like the community has been
pretty react reactive there's like
flying in these models
but if like a pretty hard problem I
would say like we're evolving the
strategies as we go since we went from
like having a few thousand models to
like 100 000 models like
getting increasingly hard
I see there's another cat
um
hello
yes
uh yeah so my question is slightly
open-ended but uh is there a reason why
only Bert like encoder only models seem
to dominate in Nar and ner and
classification tasks
and like why don't we see like something
like T5 or GPD like models sort of
giving us good results and benchmarks
um
sure
um I can again give kind of like my
intuition why that's so but anybody who
has like a different opinion is very
like
free to to chime in so the the intuition
behind IP encoder and decoder
architecture that's kind of like what T5
doesn't the bird models they're kind of
only an enclosure model T5 is an
enclosure decoder and then you have GT3
that's why or gp2 that's like just the
decoder
um and the way I think about encoder
decoders is the goal of the encoder is
to compress the information of like the
input tens into as much useful
information as necessary such that the
decoder can do its job and the job of
the decoder is to take that information
and start generating output text right
in case of T5 you have like maybe a
sentence in in uh in English and you
want to translate into French so the
goal of the encoder is compressed like
the semantic meaning of being this
sentence in a useful format such that
the decoder can then generate
um
the the text from the top Architects
which would be French so the goal of the
decoder is to take take some vector and
create text from it but for example if
you want to do an entry recognition that
step is not really needed right you
don't need to generate x coordinate
entry explanation
um I think with T5 did it's kind of like
reinfraid some some of the tasks
um that are like sentencing recognition
or classification as text to test text
to text tasks but it doesn't need to be
that way and it's maybe like even like a
step too far and that's why like for
many tasks that only require like
understanding
um like I would say classification and
entry recognition or question answering
you only need the encoded part that
tastes like the input information input
text and compresses it into some useful
uh vector and then you add that final
head to it that just um that's the task
you want to do and for for other tasks
like translation I think these sequences
sequence mode or encoding decoder models
are what's what are dominating
and for like just text Generation
Um I think GT models that are only
decoder are dominating
um
but you you can kind of like abuse any
any of the architecture for any of the
other tasks right you can also use cheat
between to do future classification
um but I think the reason why like bird
models are still like competitive
different ones that are like 100 times
bigger is that they're like their
architectures like just very viewed or
that type of task
I said to answer your question
yeah thanks uh a follow-up question
though so like uh if let's say we drop
off the decoder part of a T5 and only
use the encoder uh do you think it will
perform better or worse than the entire
model
considering that encoder decoder models
actually are double the parameter size
right
so like is it something specific about
just the encoder and a classification
head that makes it so good
um good question I I don't know if
anybody
has done that but I would expect that it
could work in general I guess it depends
a little bit on like how much data you
have because like the the objective of
T5 is kind of quite different from an
objective that a great life model has
and if you then
just want to fine-tune the the enclosure
or something like that maybe you need a
little bit more data and a model that
has been already pre-trained with that
objective but it wouldn't be that hard I
think to run an experiment
uh if I may interject uh so I don't know
about whether this has been done on T5
but I don't I know that it has been done
on uh embarked so this is also an
encoder decoder Transformer and the
decoder has been used as part of a
speech recognition task so basically
having a speech encoder and reusing the
decoder from Bart so that seems to work
extremely well just by retraining the
cross attention
and uh yeah you can do multiple things
of course like I think adding adapters
between the encoder or the decoder or
just using uh the output of the encoder
as this and it seems to work well Works
quite well
ah that sounds interesting could you uh
possibly give me a paper link for that
work
s oh yeah sure I will send it in chat
thanks
[Music]
thanks for sharing
um let me see there's another question
foreign
do any reference three metrics exist for
a neural multilingual nerd task leverage
besides the reference space Matrix
mentioned in the book
also what are your thoughts on reference
three metrics about working on evaluate
when you come across some metrics
designed to be reference free by Nature
developments in the field
um good question so I
think about it but I don't think I know
of any like
reference three metrics for neuro or
multilingual nerve uh on the top of my
head and I think in general like
for for many supervised tasks like
reference metrics are useful in the
sense that
um I mean the the tough part usually is
figuring out which one is the right
metric to use but once you have like a
metric that you're confident
about uh reflects what you're trying to
achieve
um they're pretty efficient in at
measuring that but to be honest I
haven't been using uh or seeing
reference free metrics for supervised
tasks that much
[Music]
um
yeah I don't think
yeah I don't think I have much more
knowledge I've consider than that how
quickly sorry
um a reference free metric uh I think is
a metric that doesn't come with a label
so you try to measure
um
the how good your predictions are
without having access to what called
labels
are there any other questions or things
you want to discuss I still have a
couple of minutes
I have one
uh yeah
no no
we can talk about cats later no no
uh I have a question regarding memory
mapping which is the mechanism which
like the data sets Library uses uh so I
want to know if it makes if memory
mapping only makes sense when you is
more efficient when you cannot load your
data set in memory or is it more
efficient overall
um so it comes with a trade-off right
because the the memory is not as fast as
disk in in general right so if you want
to do certain things
if you load them into memory you can do
things faster than if you have to go to
memory sometimes and read some data
um that being said for example if you
work in in NLP you usually you're not
concentrated by speed of processing like
processing text is like super fast right
applying Red X to a terabyte of data is
not the problem it's like loading a
terabyte of data in memory that's
usually very important bottleneck is
um in the data sets Library you can do
both you can also load the data in
memory if you want there's uh I think
there's a flag that you can use
um it's like speed is an issue
but how would you load the data in
memory if if like if you have a One DB
data set then oh yeah then you can
right so that is that uh my question
what is is that well memory mapping
helps uh as opposed to
yeah so so the the main cool feature of
memory mapping is you don't need any
memory to do your operations right you
you load data kind of on demand into
memory
um okay which can be an issue with
certain modalities usually respects
yeah
but yeah it's uh
the the main selling point is you don't
need to keep your data in memory
okay and uh maybe a tangential question
if if say I want to uh run five
experiments uh on one machine
and all of the five experiments are
using one data set which can be loaded
in memory
it's is there uh any Library uh
that can help me do that because if I
launch it in multiple times and that
data set will get launched five times uh
that data set will get loaded into
memory five times but I want all five
uh
trading runs to reference that one uh
memory uh one data set loaded in memory
so you essentially want to share your
memory across processors
okay
I
don't know I don't I think I mean just
doing it nicely seems to be a hard
problem I don't think you can easily
access the memory of another process
like if it's just pure python
um what I could imagine could work if
you run like kind of a server that's or
like a process that acts as like a
server where you can like call and it
gives you some some data
that makes sense for you yeah you spin
up at one python process uh that loads
the data and you can't call that python
service or how you want to call it and
it gives you like data and multiple
processes can can do it
but if if your worry is to not load the
data set multiple times if you're using
like the
hunt based dataset is going to be the
same exact Arrow table on disk that's
being used
right but uh yeah uh if I load if I if I
have five python processes running
won't they uh
and and you are the interface data set
is memory map so it will only load data
on demand
won't my memory consumption increase as
I increase the number of training runs
um but you won't use any memory
for any process right because they all
don't they only look at the data that
they currently need
foreign because they're all memory
mapped
right there are all memory Maps so let's
say process a launches uh
one uh like index indices one to five in
my data set process B uh is at a
training stage where it's loading five
to ten uh indices in my data set
and those
uh
so that portion of the data set loaded
in memory before
uh before
you process them
I guess I need to throw it out to
explain it
yeah so you're meaning like you
essentially process about a different
batch on each process and so yeah if you
have five processes you might have five
batches in memory at a certain point
yeah that sounds about right okay but
but I think what you suggested would
work is have a separate python process
that sort of serves that data in memory
and have
the other processes talk to that process
somehow
yeah that would be like I mean with
something like Fast API you can build
like a prototype pretty quickly
that's like just something that you can
call from another typing process but
yeah I I think it depends a lot on like
how the concrete setup is in terms of
like bandwidth and
data you need to send around or these
things might break down
also would be interesting to see if it
works in data sets or if you can make
the working data sets so if you compare
some example or code I'm also happy to
like give it a shot
yeah again uh I can share something
cool I think you're already a few
minutes over time
that went quickly
um
thanks everyone for joining
um I'll put up uh another survey
um for the next chapter in Discord I
think we have like probably one more
session we can do before Christmas so
Chris can convert his Christmas sweater
again
because the chance of seeing cats no
I'll wear the other one
nice
what do we still have to vote on I
remember text generation still
um being up for voting and
we know that we did a few maybe we can
add some more to the pool I mean as I
said I think so far we went from like in
order through the book but we don't
necessarily need to do it that way but
it seems like that's what people want to
do so
happy to follow along
all right if it grew up to me I would
start at the end introduce for it
what's the end like the index
yeah
let's go through the index
I'm Grand Pendleton page 133
and grams 152.
short question like if you save model
you know hugging face save a lot of
model of course you save the parameters
uh you know it's back to my original
question like
um
support yeah like gbt you have a 175
billion or whatever parameter you save
that but suppose you train the model
on certain Corpus and you have a
vocabulary support and makeup number
uh 100 000 vocabulary the science
so where do you save do you save with
the contextual embedding for the 110 000
or 100 000 uh a token after the training
or you only save the parameter and
architecture of the model
uh so those are safe in like two pieces
plus the token either that was one thing
which is a related to like the
vocabulary and the other thing is that
the weights of the model that are also
saved
um but I think most uh the question if
that's something to post a question on
Discord and then we can continue there
uh sorry Chris you want to say something
uh I just wanted to ask what you mean by
contextual embeddings it could be that
we're like thinking of different things
when you when you say contextual
embeddings could it be that you mean the
input
embedding Matrix that turns like the
one-hard vectors into
a dense Vector is this what you yeah
that's what I mean I mean this is not
this is not a contextual embedding this
is a static lookup style embedding every
word in the vocabulary gets mapped to
the same Vector every time
um
and this is just a static Matrix
but after this mapping after the
training each token will be associated
with a dense Vector of a certain
Dimension like a 768 or whatever yes so
that's what I mean to embedding yeah
this yeah that's storage with the model
yeah it's it's story which is the model
right yep yeah oh okay okay that's what
I want to know yeah thank you you think
people call that like the embedding
Matrix yeah okay so contextual lifestyle
yeah or input embedding sometimes also
okay okay good good good nice all right
okay
all right have a nice evening have a
nice day and see you in two weeks bye
everyone thanks bye guys
thank you